we had a had to take
big dog to Thailand years ago and uh we
did this great video of the robot
walking in the sand walking into the
ocean up to I don't know its belly or
something like that and then turning
around and walking out all while playing
some cool beach music yeah great show
but then you know we didn't really clean
the robot off and the salt water was
really hard on it so you know we put it
in a box shipped it back by the time it
came back we had some problems with salt
it's the salt water it's not like old
stuff it's not like sand getting into
the components or something like this
but I'm sure if if this is a big
priority you can make it like waterproof
right that just wasn't our our goal at
the time well it's a personal goal of
mine to it walk along the beach but it's
a human problem too you get sand
everywhere it's it's just a jam mess
so soft surfaces are okay so I mean can
we just uh link on the the robotics
challenge there's um there's a pile of
uh like Rubble they had to walk over is
that's
um how difficult is that task
in the early days of developing big dog
the loose Rock was the epitome of the
hard walking surface because he stepped
down and then the Rock and you had these
little Point feet on the robot
and The Rock can roll and and you have
to deal with that last minute you know
change in your foot placement yes so you
step on the thing and that thing
responds to you stepping on it yeah and
and it moves where your point of support
is and so it's really that that became
kind of the essence of the test and so
that was the beginning of us starting to
build Rock piles in our parking lots and
and we would actually build boxes full
of rocks and bring them into the lab and
then we would have the robots walking
across these boxes of rocks because that
became the essential test
so you mentioned big dog can you can we
maybe take a stroll through the history
of Boston Dynamics uh so what and who is
Big Dog by the way is who
do you try not to anthropomorphize the
robots do you try not to to try to
remember that they're this is like the
division I have because I for me it's
impossible for me there's a magic to the
to the being that is a robot it is not
human but it is
the the same Magic
uh the living being has when it moves
about the world is there in the robot so
um I don't know what question I'm asking
but uh should I say what or who I guess
who is Big Dog what is big dog
well I'll say to address the medic
question we don't try to draw hard lines
around it being an it or a him or a her
um it's okay right people I think part
of the magic of these kinds of machines
is by nature of their organic movement
of the of their Dynamics
we tend to want to identify with them we
tend to look at them and sort of
attribute
maybe feeling to that because we've only
seen things that move like this that
were alive
and so
um this is an opportunity it means that
you could have
feelings for a machine and you know
people have feelings for their cars you
know they get attracted to them attached
to them so that's inherently could be a
good thing as long as we manage what
that interaction is
so we don't put strong boundaries around
this and ultimately think it's a benefit
but it's also can be a bit of a curse
because I think people look at these
machines
and they attribute a level of
intelligence that the machines don't
have why because again they've seen
things move like this that we're living
beings
which are intelligent
and so they want to attribute
intelligence to the robots that isn't
appropriate yet even though they move
like an intelligent being but you try to
acknowledge that the
anthropomorphization is there and try to
first of all acknowledge that it's there
and have a little fun with it you know
our most recent video it's just kind of
fun you know to to look at the robot we
started off the the video with Atlas
um kind of looking around for where the
bag of tools was because the guy up on
the scaffolding says send me some tools
and Atlas has to kind of look around and
see where they are and there's a little
personality there that is fun it's
entertaining it makes our jobs
interesting and I think in the long run
can enhance interaction between humans
and robots that in a way that isn't
available to machines that don't move
that way this is something to me
personally is very interesting I've been
um
I happen to have a lot of legged robots
I hope uh to have a lot of spots in my
possession
um I'm interested in celebrating
Robotics and celebrating companies and I
also don't want to companies that do
incredible stuff like Boston Dynamics
and I there's a
you know I'm a little crazy and you say
you don't want to you you want to align
you want to help the company because I
ultimately want a company that busted an
image to succeed and part of that we'll
talk about you know success kind of
requires making money
and so the kind of stuff I'm
particularly interested in may not be
the thing that makes money in the short
term I can make an argument they will in
the long term but the kind of stuff I've
been playing with is a robust way of uh
having the quadruped the robot dogs
communicate in motion with their body
movement the same kind of stuff you do
with it with a dog but not not
hard-coded but in a robust way and be
able to communicate excitement or fear
boredom all this kinds of stuff and I
think as a base layer
of function of behavior to add on top of
a robot I think that's a really powerful
way uh to make the robot more usable for
humans for whatever application it's
going to be really important and um it's
a thing we're we're beginning to pay
attention to
um we really want to start a
differentiator for the company has
always been we really want the robot to
work we want it to be useful
and making it work at first meant the
legged Locomotion really works it can
really get around and it doesn't fall
down and
um but beyond that it now it needs to be
a useful tool and our customers are
for example Factory owners people who
are running a process manufacturing
facility and the robot needs to be able
to get through this complex facility in
a reliable way you know taking taking
measurements
we need for people who are operating
those robots to understand what the
robots are doing
if the robot gets into needs help or or
you know is in trouble or something it
needs to be able to communicate
and a physical indication of some sort
uh to so that a person looked at the
robot and goes oh I know what that's
that robot's doing the robot's going to
go take measurements of my vacuum pump
with its thermal camera
you know you want to be able to indicate
that and or even just the robots
um about to turn you know in front of
you and maybe indicate that it's going
to turn and so you sort of see and can
anticipate its motion so these this kind
of communication is going to become more
and more important it wasn't sort of our
starting point
um you know but now the the robots are
really out in the world and you know we
have about a thousand of them out with
with customers right now
this layer of physical indication I
think is going to become more and more
important we'll talk about where it goes
because there's a lot of interesting
possibilities but if you can return back
to the origins of Boston and Dynamics
with so that the more research the r d
side before we talk about how to build
robots at scale so big dog so um who's
Big Dog so the company started in 1992.
and in um probably uh uh 2003
I believe is when we uh took a contract
from darpto basically 10 years 11 years
um we weren't doing robotics we did a
little bit of Robotics with Sony they
had uh IBO the their IBO robot we were
developing some software for that that
kind of got us a little bit involved
with robotics again then there's this
opportunity to do a DARPA contract where
they wanted to build
a robot dog and uh we we won a contract
to build that and so that was the
Genesis of big dog
and it was a quadruped and it was the
first time we built a robot that had
everything on board that you could
actually take the robot out into the
wild and operate it so it had onboard
power plant it had onboard computers it
had
hydraulic actuators that needed to be
cooled so we had cooling systems built
in
everything integrated into the robot
and uh that was a pretty rough start
right it was it was 10 years that we
were not a robotics company we were a
simulation company and then we had to
build a robot in about a year so that
was a little bit of a rough transition
um
can you just comment on the roughness of
that transition because uh big dog I
mean this is just big
uh quadruped four legs robot rebuilt a
few different versions of them but the
first one you're the very earliest ones
you know it didn't work very well and we
would take them out and it was hard to
get you know uh
you know a go-kart engine driving a
hydraulic that's not what it was
and and you know uh having that all work
uh while trying to get you know the
robot to stabilize itself and so what
was the power plan what was the engine
it seemed like uh my vague direct
collection
I don't know it felt very loud and
aggressive and uh kind of thrown
together that's what it kind of oh it
absolutely was right we weren't trying
to design the best robot Hardware at the
time
and uh we wanted to buy an off-the-shelf
engine and so many of the early versions
of big dog had literally go-kart engines
or something like that usually yeah like
a yeah gas powered two-stroke engine
and the reason why it was two-stroke is
two-stroke engines are lighter weight
but they're also and we we generally
didn't put Mufflers on them because
we're trying to save the weight and we
didn't care about the noise and so these
things were horribly loud
um but we're trying to manage weight
because managing weight in a legged
robot is always important because it has
to carry everything
that said that thing was big well I've
seen the videos yeah I mean the the
early versions you know stood about I
don't know belly High chest High
um you know they probably weighed maybe
a couple of hundred pounds but you know
it over the course of probably five
years
we are able to get that robot
to really manage a remarkable level of
rough terrain so you know we started out
with just walking on the flat and then
we started walking on rocks and then
inclines and then mud and slippery mud
and you know by the end of that program
we were convinced that legged Locomotion
in a robot could actually work because
you know going into it we didn't we
didn't know that we had built quadrupeds
at at MIT
but they were they used a giant
hydraulic pump you know in the lab they
used a giant computer that was in the
lab they were always Tethered to the lab
this was the first time something that
was sort of self-contained you know
walked around in the world
um and balance but and the purpose was
to prove to ourselves that the legged
Locomotion could really work and so um
big dog really cut that open for us and
it was the beginning of what became a
whole series of robots so once once we
showed to DARPA that you could make it
like a robot that could work
there was a period at DARPA where
robotics got really hot and there was
lots of different programs
and uh you know we were able to build
other robots we built other quadrupeds
to hand like LS3
designed to carry heavy loads we built
cheetah which was designed to explore
what are the limits to how fast you can
run you know we began to build sort of a
portfolio
of machines and software that let us
build not just one robot but a whole
family everyone to push the limits in
all kinds of directions yeah and to
discover those principles you know you
asked earlier about the Art and Science
of a leg and locomotion
we it were able to develop principles of
legged Locomotion so that we knew how to
build
a small legged robot or a big one so the
leg like length you know was now a
parameter that we could play with
payload was a parameter we could play
with so we built the LS3 which was an
800 pound robot designed to carry a 400
pound payload
and we we learned the design rules
basically developed the design rules how
do you scale different robot systems to
you know their terrain to their walking
speed to their payload
so when uh was spot born
around
2000 and uh 12 or so so again almost 10
years into sort of a run with DARPA
where we built a bunch of different
quadrupeds we had a sort of a different
thread where we started building
humanoids
um we we saw that probably an end was
coming where the government was going to
kind of back off from a lot of Robotics
investment
and uh in order to maintain progress we
just deduced that well we probably need
to sell ourselves to somebody who wants
to continue to invest in this this area
and that was Google
and so
um at Google we would meet regularly
with Larry Page and Larry just started
asking us you know what's your product
going to be and you know the logical
thing the thing that we had the most
history with that we wanted to continue
developing was our quadruped but we knew
it needed to be smaller we knew it
couldn't have a gas engine we thought it
probably couldn't be hydraulically
actuated
so that began the process of exploring
if we could migrate to a smaller
electrically actuated
um robot and that was really the Genesis
of spot
so not a gas engine and the actuators
are electric yes so can you maybe
comment on what it's like
um my Google working with Larry Page
having those meetings and thinking of
what will a robot look like
that could be
built that scale what like starting to
think about a product
Larry always liked the the toothbrush
test he wanted products that you used
every day
um
what they really wanted was
you know a consumer level product
something that would work in your house
we didn't think that was the right next
thing to do because to be a consumer
level product cost is going to be very
important
probably need to cost a few thousand
dollars and we were we were building
these machines that cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars maybe a million
dollars to build of course we were only
building a two but
but we didn't see how to get all the way
to this consumer level product in a
short amount in a short amount of time
and he suggested that we we make the
robots really inexpensive
and part of our philosophy has always
been
build the best hardware you can
make make the machine operate well
so that you're trying to solve
you know discover the the hard problem
that you don't know about don't don't
make it harder by building a crappy
machine basically build the best machine
you can there's plenty of hard problems
to solve that are going to have to do
with you know under actuated systems and
balance
and so we wanted to build these high
quality machines still and we thought
that was important for us to continue
learning about really what was the
important parts of the make robots work
um and so there was a little bit of a
philosophical difference there that we
and and so ultimately that's why we're
building robots for the industrial
sector now because the industry can
afford a more expensive machine because
you know their productivity depends on
keeping their Factory going and so if
spot costs you know a hundred thousand
dollars or more that's not such a big
expense to them whereas at the consumer
level no one's going to buy a robot like
that and I think we might eventually get
to a consumer level product that will be
that cheap but I think the path to
getting there needs to go through these
really nice machines so we can then
learn how to simplify
so what can you say to the almost the
engineering challenge of bringing down
costs
of a robot so that presumably when you
try to build the robot at scale that
also comes into play when you're trying
to make money on a robot even in the
industrial setting but how interesting
how challenging
of of a thing is that in particular
probably new to an r d company yeah I'm
glad you brought that last part up the
transition from an r d company to a
commercial company
that's the thing you worry about you
know because you've got these Engineers
who love hard problems who want to
figure out how to make robots work and
you don't know if you have Engineers
that want to work on the quality and
reliability and costs that is ultimately
required
um and indeed you know we have brought
on a lot of new people who are inspired
by those problems
but but the big takeaway lesson for me
is
we have good people we have Engineers
who want to solve problems and and the
quality and cost and manufacturability
is just another kind of problem
and because they're so invested in what
we're doing they're interested in and
we'll go work on on those problems as
well and so I think we're managing that
transition very well in fact I'm really
pleased that
I mean uh it's a huge undertaking by the
way right so you know even having
to get reliability to where it needs to
be we have to have fleets of robots that
we're just operating 24 7 in our offices
to go find those rare failures and
eliminate them it's just a totally
different kind of activity than the
research activity where you get it to
work you know the one robot you have to
work in a repeatable way you know at the
at the high stakes demo it's just very
different
um but I think we're making remarkable
progress against it so one of the cool
things that got a chance to visit Boston
Dynamics and I mean
one of the things that's really cool is
to see a large number of robots moving
about
because I think one of the things you
notice in the research environment is
the MIT for example I don't think anyone
ever has a working robot for prolonged
exactly so like most robots are just
sitting there in a sad
state of despair waiting to be born
brought to life for a brief moment of
time but just to have I just I just
remember there's like a there's a spot
robot just I I had like a cowboy hat on
it was just walking randomly for
whatever reason I don't even know but
there's a kind of a sense of sentience
to it because it doesn't seem like
anybody was supervising it he was just
doing it I'm gonna stop way short of the
sentience
um it is the case that if you come to
our office you know today and walk
around the hallways
um you're gonna see a dozen robots just
kind of walking around yes all the time
and that's really a reliability test for
us so we have these robots programmed to
do autonomous missions get up off their
charging dock walk around the building
collect data at a few different places
and go sit back down and we want that to
be a very reliable process because
that's what somebody who's running a
brewery a factory that's what they need
the robot to do and so we have to we
have to dog food our own robot we have
to test it in that way
and um so on a weekly basis we have
robots that are accruing something like
um 1500 or maybe 2 000 kilometers of
walking
and uh you know over a thousand hours of
operation every week and that's
something that almost I don't think
anybody else in the world can do because
hey you have to have a fleet of robots
to just accrue that much information
you have to be willing to dedicate it to
that test and uh so that's but that's
essential that's how you get the
reliability that's how you get it what
about some of the cost cutting from the
from the manufacturer side what what
have you learned from the manufacturer
side of the transition from r d and
we're still we're still learning a lot
there
um we're learning how to cast Parts in
Solo instead of Mill it all out of you
know Billet aluminum
um we're learning how to get plastic
molded parts for and we're learning
about how to control that process so
that you can build the same robot twice
in a row there's a lot to learn there
and we're only part way through that
process
um we've we've set up a manufacturing
facility in Waltham it's about a mile
from our headquarters and we're doing
final assembly and test of both spots
and stretches you know at that factory
and um
and it's hard because to be honest we're
still iterating on the design of the
robot as we find failures from these
reliability tests we need to go engineer
changes and those changes need to now be
propagated to the manufacturing line and
that's a hard process especially when
you want to move as fast as we do
and that's been challenging and it makes
it you know the folks who are working
supply chain who are trying to get the
cheapest parts for us kind of requires
that you buy a lot of them to make them
cheap and then we go change the design
from underneath them and they're like
what are you doing and so you know
getting everybody on the same page here
that it yep we still need to move fast
but we also need to try to figure out
how to reduce costs that's one of the
challenges of of this migration we're
going through and over the past few
years challenges to the supply chain I
mean I imagine you've been a part of a
bunch of stressful meetings yeah things
got more expensive and harder to get and
yeah so it's it's all been a challenge
is there still room for simplification
oh yeah much more and you know these are
really just the first generation of
these machines we're already thinking
about what the next generation of spots
going to look like
spot was built as a platform so you
could put almost any sensor on it and we
provided data Communications mechanical
connections uh Power connections
um but for example in the applications
that we're excited about where you're
you're monitoring these factories for
their health
there's probably a simpler machine that
we could build that's really focused on
that use case and that's the difference
between the general purpose machine or
the platform versus the purpose-built
machine and so even though even in the
factory we'd still like the robot to do
lots of different tasks if it's if we
really knew on day one that we're going
to be operating in a factory with these
three sensors in it we would have it all
integrated in a package that would be
easier more less expensive and more
reliable so we're contemplating building
you know a next generation of that
machine so she mentioned that there's a
spot
for people who somehow are not familiar
uh so it's a yellow robotic dog
and
um has been featured in many Dance
videos it also has gained an arm
so what can you say about the arm that
spot has about the challenges of this
design
and the manufacture of it we think the
future of mobile robots is mobile
manipulation that's where
you know in the past 10 years
it was getting Mobility to work getting
the legged look emotional work if you
ask what's the hard problem in the next
10 years
it's getting a mobile robot to do useful
manipulation for you
and so we wanted spot to have an arm to
experiment with those problems
and the arm is
um
almost as complex as the robot itself
you know and uh it's a it's an
attachable payload
um it has you know several Motors and
actuators and sensors it has a camera in
the end of its hand so you know you can
sort of see something
the and the robot will control the
motion of its hand to go pick it up
autonomously so in the same way the
robot walks and balances managing its
own foot placement to stay balanced we
want manipulation to be mostly
autonomous where the robot you indicate
okay go grab that bottle and then the
robot will just go do it using the
camera in its hand and then sort of
closing in on that um the grasp
but it's it's a whole nother complex
robot on top of a complex legged robot
and so and of course we made it the hand
look a little like a head you know
because again we want it to be sort of
identifiable in the last year a lot of
our sales have been people who already
have a robot now buying an arm to add to
that robot oh interesting and so the the
armor is for sale oh yeah oh yeah it's
an option what's the what's the
interface like to work with the arm like
is it pretty so are they designed
primarily I guess just ask that question
in general about robots from Boston
Dynamics is it designed to be
easily and efficiently operated remotely
by a human being or is there also the
capability to push towards autonomy
we want both
uh in the next version of the software
that we release uh which will be version
3.3 we're going to offer the ability of
if you have a autonomous mission for the
robot we're going to include the option
that it can go through a door which
means it's going to have to have an arm
and it's gonna have to use that arm to
open the door
and so that'll be an autonomous
manipulation task that just you can
program easily uh with the robot
strictly through you know we have a
tablet interface and so on the tablet
you know you sort of see the The View
that spot sees you say there's the door
handle you know the hinges are on the
left and it opens in the rest is up to
you take care oh so it just takes care
of everything yeah so we we want in for
a task like opening doors you can
automate most of that and we've
automated a few other tasks we had a
customer
who had a high-powered breaker switch
essentially it's an electric utility
Ontario power generation
and they have to when they're going to
disconnect you know their power supply
right that could be a gas generator
could be a nuclear power plant you know
from the grid you have to disconnect
this breaker switch as you can imagine
there's you know hundreds or thousands
of amps and volts involved in this
breaker switch
and it's a dangerous event because
occasionally you'll get what's called an
arc flash as you just do this disconnect
the power the Sparks jump across and
people die doing this
and so uh Ontario power generation used
our spot and and the arm through the
interface to to operate this this
disconnect
um that's right in an interactive way
and they showed it to us
and we were so excited about it and said
you know I bet we can automate that task
and so we we got some examples of that
breaker switch and I believe in the next
generation of the software now we're
going to deliver back to Ontario power
generation they're going to be able to
just point the robot
at that breaker so we have to indicate
that's the switch there's sort of two
actions you have to do you have to flip
up this little cover press a button then
get a ratchet stick it in to a socket
and literally unscrew this giant breaker
switch so there's a bunch of different
tasks and we basically automated them so
that the human says okay there's the
switch go do that part
that right there is the socket where
you're going to put your tool and you're
going to open it up and so you can
remotely sort of indicate this on the a
tablet and then the robot just does
everything in between and it does
everything all the coordinated movement
of all the different actuators that
include the body and it maintains its
balance it it walks itself you know into
position so it's within reach and the
arm is in a position where it can do the
whole task so it manages uh the whole
body so how does one become a big enough
customer to request features because I
personally want a robot that gets me
beer
I mean that has to be like one of the
most requests I suppose in the
industrial setting that's uh a
non-alcoholic beverage
um of picking up objects and bringing
the objects to you we love working with
customers who have challenging problems
like this and and this one in particular
because we felt like what they were
doing a it was a safety feature B we saw
that the robot could do it because they
they tele operated it the first time
probably took him an hour to do it the
first time right but the robot was
clearly capable
and we thought oh this is a great
problem for us to work on to figure out
how to automate a manipulation task and
so we took it on not not because we were
going to make a bunch of money from it
and selling the robot back to them but
because it motivated us to go solve what
we saw as the next logical step
but many of our customers in fact uh we
we try to our bigger customers who
typically ones who are going to run a
utility or a factory or something like
that
we take that kind of direction from them
and if they're especially if they're
going to buy 10 or 20 or 30 robots and
they say I really needed to do this well
that's exactly the right kind of problem
that we want to be working on and and so
note to self buy 10 spots
and aggressively push for beer
manipulation
I think